more pride educational videos since we
talked about non-binary last time
how about we bring up the idea of
pronouns specifically i want to talk
about
um they them pronouns now this is
something that honestly
should not be as contentious as it is
but long story short there are some
people who get confused by or
get angry about the fact that some
people prefer
they them pronouns now i will grant it
is very much ingrained in the english
language that they them is plural and it
can
take some work to sort of wrench your
brain into thinking about individuals
that way but i guarantee you you are
already doing it
even if you're not aware of it when you
have conversations or say things about
someone who you don't know their
identity
you are almost guaranteed to use them by
default
oh that somebody cut me off in traffic
who do they think they are
you've probably done something like that
so you can't claim that it doesn't work
as a singular it does
you just kind of have to get used to
using it to refer to a specific
individual who you know
and that takes some work